.
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT, ONCE AGAIN
THIS M. W.TEHALLEN
THAT PUT I
REPUBLICAN-LED STATES,TH SAYINAE
DN H,
.ADINGHI
THFORDABLE CARREMAINS
E 20 MILLION
WILL CONE E COVERAGE
BECA COU SIRNING.
BLLICANS  OTHER PLAFFT FIND A
ENGE THIS LA
OIDS
IUSE HISTRATI
THUMP ADST
AT STRUCK
E A PROCAL
TO UPHOLD AW.
O KEEP T TACT FOR ARD T.
PRETZE LAW SD THAT MAJORITY
ANE STAT MUST ALA BEUS DEN NI
IT.THAT WAS TTICES INN A 7-
DECISION, KEEPING INTACT, THE
CARE ACT.
>> T Y, ICT RERTRIGHT LEGAYST, I
AND ABBY PHILLIP, THE HOST SUNDI
ARGUMENTS, TE ORIGINAL
WHATSICA IBAK
ON UT, FTIVE TEEBERAL-THIS CLL>.
PLAINTIFFS
ORAKED
ROBERTS D VANAUGH WERE KE CHIEFS
SKEPTICAL.
THE AG RTS IS TRYIN
THFOT,ECADE, I MCONSERVATIVES,
THROE POCAL PROCESS.E COURTS T
AWRESIDEASLDRU
THE HOUSE WE I
RES A SUEM COULDN'T COME A
CHANGES
THIS ISN'T TE-SEW HAVESERRALL  V
USLE WITISTINGND P KEEP THE KID
THERE'S NO LIME MI
THESE ARE PARTS OF AMERICAN
LIAT IN THOUGHRTOR AHITIME, THDH
AFFORDABLE CARE T FO UNTIL THEAF
E BROUGHBYDOESGAIN.NGTHENE NO
REPUANTA CHIEFLY S.
WHAT DO SEE AS THE
'S TRUE FROM THE PERSPECIS  A
OFD THEIR NCE.
BUT POLITICALLY, THERE'S
THCITHE RESUS DE. VIRTUALLYSUE F
AFFORDABLCA
ACT, REPEALING IT,CING
S MORE OEALY RIGHT
IT'S BEEN A R FO
S CONTROL OVER THE WHICO HOUSE E
EY T
LEGISLATIVELY CHANGE THIS .
AS AS ON IT MORE UNLIKELY.
E DY SUP C
BUT IT'S POLITICAL LOSER FOR
REPUBLANA LEGAR REPUBLICANS.
FOR AT REASON,
POLITICAL MOMENT.
YOU'LL SEENS MOVININIRECTIPUTHE.
THINKING TS IONDING,EA WFOTUREHA
PLAINTIFFS WHO HAVE .
E --OREMBE YOUAS CONEYRE
HAVE LIBERALS, W STANDING.LENGET
JOHN ROBER AROE FRINH OFO E ETI
AND  IS COVERED
SURVIVESINOURT  ILUDES RRT  BRE
E WIND I
THE SAILS OF PEOPLE WHO
OBAMARET
ET OF IT.
LITICA I
E  RULIN
REME COURT DIOON THEBLE CARE ACT
IT'S IOR TO NOTE THIION., THE SO
F
THAT IESN, CARD THALRO
ATTER WH
OBPLAY SPOKE ABBY,
AND THAT WMESSAGR TWELECTIONT
IS THIAN NPAIGNS
THAT, TH SEEY PELOSI C CLAIMIC
ANIMATEOR DO SEEM
IS NO LONGER A WINNER?Y DOUBT IL
F ISSUES.
ONRI THEOREN THE BOR
.HAVING A  TE BALLOT BOX OVETHI
, IT'S A MAJOR
SIDEE SUNC
WANTR PRE-NG NDD MANY WAN
EX ROLOF
SOME WAYS IN HEALTH , BY
MOVING TOW SOMETNGAPOA
PO